tonight we welcome to the podium we on
career who is the inaugural
turn visiting professor and architecture
this new chair is intended to maintain
the presence among those teaching
advanced studios of architects committed
to the continuity of classical and
traditional architecture as part of the
wider field why is your thing flying
along here
that's only flying on your on this
screen yes I'm getting the whole lecture
here the chairs intended as I said to
maintain the presence among those
teaching advanced studios of Architects
committed to the continuity of classical
and traditional architecture as part of
the wider field of possibilities in
contemporary architecture in 2008 Robert
Rosencrantz Yale College 1962 initiated
the effort to endow the stern visiting
professorship others joined him to make
the new chair a reality I am honored by
these gifts and by the faith they show
in our school and it's pluralistic
approach
Yale's architecture program with its
roots in the Fine Arts has long held
that classical and traditional
architecture provide fundamental in
underpinnings and points of reference to
the work of the present a position that
was also held by the pioneering figures
of stylistic modernism early in the 20th
century such as la Corbusier and Mies
van der Rohe ax in architecture and
Cezanne Picasso and Matisse in art as a
result of this new chair Yale will be
able to ensure its historic commitment
to the sources of the Western tradition
and in doing so offer necessary
counterbalance to the explorations
ongoing of the avant-garde I can think
of no one more appropriate to inaugurate
the CERN chair than we on career he was
long been a friend of the school
professor Correa studied architecture at
the University of Stuttgart short cart
from 1968 to 1974 he worked in close
professional collaboration with James
Stirling since then he has held faculty
appointments at the architectural
Association and Royal College of Arts in
London Princeton University in New
Jersey and the University of Virginia at
Yale in 2001 he shared the Eero Saarinen
visiting professorship in partnership
with Andres Duany and he is held the
William B and Charlotte Deborah
Davenport visiting professorship on six
separate occasions initially in
partnership with demetri porphyrios in
1991 then without benefit of partnership
in 2002 2003 2005 2007 and 2009 most
recently in 2013
professor career was the Luas icon
visiting professor professor korea's
contributions to the discipline as a
modern architect dedicated to classical
and vernacular traditions have earned
him a place as one of our most important
practitioner theorists a place that has
been repeatedly and widely recognized he
was awarded the Berlin Prize for
architecture in 1977 the Thomas
Jefferson Memorial gold medal in 1985
the Chicago American Institute of
Architects award in 1987 European
culture prize in 1995 in Caen in 2003 he
was awarded the Driehaus Prize for
classical and traditional architecture
and in 2006 the Athena medal of the
Congress for the New Urbanism
he is the author of numerous articles
and books including architecture choice
or faith published in 1997 for which he
received the silver medal of the Academy
process please join me in welcoming the
inaugural Robert stern visiting
professor in classical and traditional
architecture leone career as
rivers a lecture LC after LC have to get
the title out the core busy translated
corrected and completed Mayo very
touching introduction I hope you won't
be too disappointed there is nothing
more difficult than to lecture to
friends I'm used to lecture to enemies
but but this is not an easy subject and
particularly as now there are two new
books being published of by another
Frenchman on copies is actually
involvement with French fascism and it
was true involvement so but cosy is an
is a figure which was for me it was my
first chosen master I couldn't work for
him because he had died by then but I
had letter from him which burned in a
fire now the idea came to me when I saw
Stanislaus from Moses book --look
opposite before the core busy and it's a
subject which we have which we could
pursue with other architects with miss
van der Rohe with Alva Otto but I have
little interest for those people I have
enormous interest for core busy despite
no my change or my involvement with
traditional architecture and the reason
why I was became so involved was because
I grew up in this town which was
absolutely a perfect town made of
Medieval and Renaissance and Baroque and
military architecture Belle Epoque
architecture
it was a perfect time to grow up him and
I grew up along that on that Bulevar
overlooking the the town and of course
when I started to be interested in
architecture I started reading Luca
Brasi and he became really my
inspiration and model and the first
project I did was very much in that
spirit
the problem was began started thinking
what shall happen if we introduce those
ideas to this beautiful city of
Luxembourg and this of course is
photographic Oh busy playing with
traditional village type architecture so
the cause was not completely lost and
there was even the family resemblance my
father looked very much like Lacaze you
see my mother was a pianist like Aziz
mother but my mother didn't like Lacaze
and except Warner she really had strong
dislike my first wife she hated la
cabeza then the girlfriend I lived with
for 16 years didn't like la cabeza she
thought mahjong is an architecture of
the stump if you know what that means
it's an so caricatural figures who were
funny
headwear but anyway this is senseless
formalism book Co busy and his father
that is me and my brother we propose
in a when modernists when they go on
holiday they talk all all the time of
been lenient you know Giordano Bruno and
all these of these characters when
modernist when classes come on holiday
they go to see cozy and this project was
this is Cabezas cabin in Hobart and is
my cabin on Maya where I did most of
this work the idea is to look at this
work again because 12 years ago I had
maybe me yeah 12 years ago I had the
studio here with mark age where we took
10 masterpieces of modernism Barcelona
pavilion we large signed the Massey in
gush and so on and placed them in a very
specific context like Williamsburg or
New York brownstone or in the Maison de
verre went into Chinatown and so the
students had to study a particular
vernacular and translate than these
masterpieces is very very well known and
recognized masterpieces into traditional
works maintaining the spirit had to be
love story it should not be a matter of
rejection and destruction but really how
to translate the qualities which are in
these works and they are at present
there how they can be translated into
traditional techniques and materials
nothing was very interesting exercise
the most interesting a student was
actually and a young Chinese beautiful
tall chinese prince who made such a
perfect project that Vincent Scully got
mad he said what's the point because it
demonstrated actually the maison de
verre could be built in China with
Chinese traditional architecture every
single move could be done
with traditional architecture so there
are parts of la cabeza which I think are
beyond redemption they are really
matters of the arranged mind
but great artists and geniuses are often
deranged and not everything that the
genius does is genius particularly when
you have absolutely no talent cause he
had no talent in urbanism he had no
sense of urbanism at all now the thing
was that he had been preceded by
brilliant thinkers like Otto Wagner
yo Serena alleles are in rather the Tony
gurney burnin all these thinkers
planners who had actually resolved
theoretically the problem of the
metropolis particularly serene icing
allele so he knows and a genius in in
conceiving the modern metropolis as
something which is more than dozen in
large small town but which is a family
of of large family of small towns Otto
Wagner had resolved it theoretically and
practically I think also architectural
II and these were such brilliant
statements that there was nothing more
to add to the theory of modern of new
urbanism and Roseate in order to be
heard had to cry wolf to really call
scandal in order to be heard
now his proposals his tongue for three
million inhabitants was not just the
town you see but when you read around
the main object you actually see
boundary boundaries no CL a sprawl what
we call sprawl so it was an
extraordinary vision of a completely
radicalized in mass society and I
compare this you know you had in the
middle that the villa reduce on the Left
how he applied it to Paris destroying
the right bank and then on the right
Albert repairs the planning for Berlin
and you see actually that the planning
for spare was rather modest compared to
the scale of Lukas
and was mixed-use also now the
apparently better me that he had the
book la Villa reduce on the table Hitler
looked and said Baba no useless cannot
be used
I know there are serious jokes you're
not supposed to laugh about this but I
wish I was Woody Allen
but his subject which needs to be looked
at from many angles and what what cause
II was victim of was the belief that the
machine was going to dictate human scale
and no longer what we are commonly what
we know as human scale but this head was
a process which had already you know
with the invention of the the steam
engine and the enormous concentration of
power which happened through this
machinery and new new energy is in : and
petrol that they thought that there
would be no more spirit no more culture
no more nothing no civilization without
the Spirit of the Machine winning but
that had preceded a busy by two or three
generations and you see these
extraordinary blowing of scale this was
with the central Paris and or Roman town
or medieval French town and they're not
in century Berlin extensions which are
already in enormous scale box of three
hundred meters long and so on no longer
made for humans to walk and then of
course copies is socialist experiment in
Vienna one kilometer long facade one
architecture when you lay this over the
center of Vienna you have I think thirty
five blocks designed by hundred and
fifty architects here you have one
architect design one single building
this is Albert repair and the co busy
after the war in Sandy so this explosion
of scale is something which went beyond
I think comprehension and this
extraordinary symbolism of the head the
lungs the spine
and the legs and feet industry culture
residents and business and when you
compare that you know what the way Roman
or medieval towns or Renaissance towns
were designed you had an extraordinary
richness of sizes of plots which allowed
great diversity of uses and of
architecture and vernacular and public
and private and religious and and
profane buildings to be from good
neighbors and create good urban space
when you have this explosion of scale
where you suddenly had larger and larger
plots with more and more uniform uses
there is very little variety for
architects to play on other than pure
formal games and because the uses are
after the uniform and it is that which
go busy in his plan radicalized that he
said not only this is a faith but is
something which we must choose because
that is the spirit of our time say
l'esprit Nouveau there is no new spirit
spirit ease you know transcends I think
novelty one of the explanations why why
a genius like the cabeza was so I think
affected by lack of urbanism was the
fact that he grew up in this new town of
the shrewd form which had been burned in
late 18th century and reconstructed in a
completely rigorous industrial manner it
was an industrial city where every
single house is a dynamo blocks but
buildings the blocks are houses which
are often oriented north-south and there
is no oven fabric to speak of whether
you could really talk of streets and
squares and something which would be our
traditional fabric so there are things
which I think are beyond
being revisited they are really bad
because you know the the northern wall
of the unity the betta showing Marseille
I didn't I didn't think anyone can can
be really excited but that's what my
mother or this I think is complete
failure it's it's the wrong kind of
architecture it's the wrong kind of idea
or this kind of plan for for LG's these
are things I think they are beyond
beyond modernity they are just bad
architecture bad urbanism and I think
they should be forgotten now the
question is how can such a genius
because when you go up on the unity it's
a poetic experience the lyrical
experience which I think surpasses even
the experience of the going up on die
propolis no it is really in a piece of
genius now Corbusier had time took time
to mature
he went to Vienna he was always very
ambitious great writer great poet he was
refused entry two years of Huffman and
to Otto Wagner and while in Vienna he
designed while in Vienna this happened
19 for 19 trial and not 5 he designed
this house villa fillet his first house
in lush route phone by correspondence
without fax or email but it is whether
one calls tick tock steel because it's
very strangely expressionist very far
away from the the rationalism for which
he would become famous then one can
identify several periods in Kaposi's
work several styles one I call
vernacular classical odd applies
virtually correctly one and this one
throws his life
this one which would be called so that
belongs still to the vernacular which
was very strongly influenced by kamila
ZT & Unwin and all these the Garden City
movement then the nautical style which
became so important in twenties which
were forms
he used forms and ideas which were
already very familiar in in Seaside
architecture in the great transatlantic
liners and we know of his love of these
constructions include sketches and so on
so you find virtually every single idea
which he used in that short period had
been preceded in nautical architecture
then there is a period way introduces a
lot of glass and a lot of steel steel
and glass so industrial materials
profoundly influenced by the miserable I
think Ken's firm has demonstrated that
very well and then there is particularly
this style of baton boot which came
after the war and which i think is
profoundly influenced by Nazi German
Albert Speer defense architecture the
Atlantic Wall which you see here an
example in by young nearby young now
it's very strange that there is now this
revelation that it was also an involved
fascist but as you know I think that
great criminals can be great artists so
I went her debt against him but not
necessarily do criminals produce
criminal architecture because it's
really what this urbanism or what that
architecture is worth beyond the regime
which they serve is also this very
extraordinary paint paint early work of
Lacaze which I think has profound roots
in bizarre and classical
representation particularly in the
analytic paintings which was a
beautifully done on the bazaar regime
and his purest paintings which I think
are really extraordinary now he of
course he had this idea to make a reel
to make himself a name and not only by
changing names but also by saying things
which were considered scandalous and I
think it's really not what he said but
they're intolerant radicality which was
new that he claimed that this is the new
world is the old world this is bad this
block must be ignored
and this is the future of five points
but there are very arbitrary points five
points of architecture you could do with
tradition luck at exception their
problem to have roof garden or pilates
or straight windows or free free plan I
reversed this just as a joke but in fact
I think Bob Stern would agree that this
is what we are doing and what we are
like what we are liking to do and what
we should as architects be better than
the industry to do so I think that is a
real mobile situation that we have to
use concrete whether you like the not
but we can also use different scales and
I think it's worth promoting traditional
technique and construction because it's
much closer to directly related to human
talent to personal talent to vocations
where you can actually encourage young
people to do jobs which are close to
that you know which they really feel and
which they can express themselves
without damaging the rest of the
community so we are now in this
situation where that system dominates
whether with the classical or
traditional buildings or modern
buildings it's often only in the in the
last few months that you actually see
the difference so what happened
with Kobe's obsession was with that
technique high-tech industrial
technology no but he a doctor this love
story with traditional technique
traditional technology because he use it
all through his life with stone walls
and prick Walton Catalan Bolton zone but
you see that most of modernism was
actually an exaggeration or quoting
sources from other fields and by that
appearing as novel on new now virtually
every form which probably used has been
used by the industry before but he put
in such an association that it creates
as a poetical power which you don't feel
when you're in front of industrial
buildings or ships shows the ability
with the last collaborative compazine I
had him on a jury once and this is why
I'm so obsessed with the cop busy I mean
he worked for coffee all his life why
didn't you study Mies van der Rohe but I
think miss one wrote did some very fine
building until he became modernist and
then he did the Barcelona pavilion which
is an absolute masterpiece and then
nothing absolute void and can you
imagine a greater nightmare and a miss
town all everything is miss I mean first
of all mrs. just unbearable and he was
an enormous talent so we are not talking
here about intelligence or talent we are
talking about what are the right or the
wrong ideas to apply to architecture so
we in this course George and I we train
students to they have first to draw the
classical buildings in 10 hence this is
famous here
historical really sort of society and
then modified them once they are
programmed to have to modify them play
around with them very 8
variation when you you can now here on
internet you can here Rachmaninoff's
piano concerto number five Rachmaninoff
wrote for piano concertos but now there
is a man called Alex's Alex
rollin back I think
and he used the second symphony of
Rachmaninoff added the piano and it's a
fifth kind of concept is fantastic it's
as good as the other ones so I think you
know these people
once these genius discover new territory
it's just like discovering a landscape
which nobody had seen and then painting
but in that landscape you can move
another facet right the 12th symphony of
Brahms why not
no it's it's really like a landscape
with the language once it's established
when they studied and talent comes
together you you get these new creations
which are extraordinary and which had
never been dent ineffable see it's
really a systematic approach to see also
to counter the movement now Kobe is the
genius he's being fitted around the
world with enormous exhibition and the
people are supposed to take it all no
good or bad supposed to be genius now I
think he had something extraordinary and
I tried to find out what it is and for
instance he exercised he did very few
classical buildings in this village walk
without choking I should fall what was
one of his let's say buildings the most
conventional buildings in the
traditional style and I think it's very
interesting plan it's very interesting
composition but it's full of really load
up I mean is really I think not very
well master the master wouldn't do that
sort of thing and also this is the house
but it has like a screen like an cinema
what and then very strange the Masters
enter here and the servants enter there
weird
and then you get lost in in in weird
situations and then but you know and
this is for instance an idea you enter
in decent way you in the courtyard and
resolve the plan composition this light
over the stack is going to write the way
through this grand plan is very good
plan and you make a real fine building
other this core busy not translate but
corrected and I'm sure we could have
convinced him it's better just have it
there need to be genius to it has very
interesting part but also very weak
parts and I think it's very important
that in face of these geniuses to to
stay critical this how you enter that's
his plan you enter and hear this strange
this were the servants and time to meet
in the stairs guys so this corrected
plan is much more systematic than home
and I think it would be an interesting
restoration to do
he obviously talked a lot about
proportion and I think he got some ideas
right which we came came from cash no
fish was a dream luckily but written the
theory of proportion which was published
in the hunt book they actually take two
of 51 odd volumes very systematic and he
used some of these which were actually
what counts I come to that later is
really the main divisions in inin it's
the main divisions within the mass of
openings or masses which count the rest
doesn't doesn't really matter the angle
its method to coordinate openings and
and volumes in a systematic way I'll
come back to that he was his very
interesting little discovery I have this
magazines called in valino italiana and
there was the doctor II prefer sorry me
cheeky or something like that want to
read who did a very similar building and
he had actually resolved the problem and
I couldn't I look everywhere I have
about 10 volumes but there is nowhere
date
it's difficult to see who copied him but
section interesting research for the
Cobb is a foundation offense you lie in
a bed here the masters lie in the bed
looking at the wall behind this for the
pigeons and then in other words you have
a beautiful landscape and you could hear
you this is this embarrassing part he
would enter into hot yard and turn
around and assume step out of your car
he used his load of trellis here the
whole penthouse would be trellis and he
would have windows around for the bed he
had the bat the bat has this looks
against that wall and then if you are
lucky you see the rascal
the bathroom has this enormous windows
with a means not mastered so this is
where where it comes I think that is
what really this is the lesson of the
ocean that the main volumes and the main
openings are harmonized by the same
diagonal whatever the proportion is but
as long as you systematize the you you
relate the openings and the volumes the
solids and the voids
you will have a harmony which is quite
powerful
things get really bad when you have this
kind of Caesarea clutter now he talked a
lot about this and I think in Varanasi
lacteal he has this drawing which is
absolutely correct relating the major
this is not actually from Venice
activities more correcting where the
major pavilions are related
whereas in the villa portion away the
diagonals go anywhere have regulate
nothing at all yeah I do know like 12
different types of window openings and
proportions and actually some vertical
openings which he condemned in his
drawing in there with in his promotion
of the horizontal window something which
was no longer mob so it is extraordinary
talent genius but doing things which are
really weird
now the proportions for instance of the
large time the mozzie has some
interesting proportions but they don't
really work I mean that is a golden
section here but the rest is not related
so he has all these lines going
everywhere and yet it's a formidable
building when you stand in front you are
really arrested I
grandiosity of this so I systematically
stubbed it the proportions of the of the
windows what is so important about win
this is the villa Fischer then there is
not one single pane which is the same
width and so you stand in front of this
building and you get the shock you don't
know exactly why but there's something
happening there which is
now this is a correction in the
modernist style because yet it's very
beautiful delicate building falls off
how was I think the main influence on
copies paintings and probably also his
change of attitude where he became a
modernist in painting and also in
architecture and then it led to the rift
I think later on the personal but it is
this very beautifully proportioned
building and then this odd zigzag again
with probably leaked and that's probably
why it was changed and is now a flat
roof above it but also here for instance
these are squares or double squares but
when you turn around on the other side
they are not the same proportion visit
inscribed equilateral triangle and this
isn't a proper square this creates this
strange a perspectival distortions when
you look at it I'm going to publish this
as book as an apocryphal volume number 9
of the ever complex
imitating because he was he was a genius
particularly also in the laying out of
books his books particularly they were
complete his system I imitated when I
did the first volume of Jim Sterling's
work
it's in a graphic as it's in a graphic
telling of a story how we go through a
building and you see everything the
whole the the part and how the part
relates to the whole and the bird's eye
view and and so on and it's very very
interesting technique I use this so
that's a immobile villa here translated
adopting the same cell
now he's their way of going back here on
the right
oh yeah okay sorry yeah so there's this
no the l-shape cell which came from the
chart hours of Elsa as he claims
and then stacked vertically into six
story high blocks purely for residential
use and but the way it is a good example
once you see the part of the cell which
was built for the 1925 exhibition of a
deco in Paris
montage in this photograph you see the
plan and then down somber so it is a
rather traditional building block but
would have ghastly effects on this side
of the street can imagine these blank
walls it's just there already was one of
the problems he had also in later
buildings this translated into with
traditional techniques that you have the
same cell the l-shaped cell with the
garden and you stack them and you can
build them in traditional architecture
you add shops on the ground floor
offices and becomes really urban
building in the same style but in a more
modest scale and probably better
surviving the weathering of our climates
that was the SP Nevada William and
that's how its translated same spirit
same proportions same space same SP
what's wrong why did you need in the
spring of all this is the same cell used
for much more modest a block of three
stories in a commercial ground floor
than these villas on top with parking
courtyard and then making an urban code
and now applied in the same style to
make know like nice water there is
something you find actually very good
modernist architecture
much better than Paris or Vienna or
anywhere in Bucharest in the these very
small villages done with beautiful
modernist architecture incredibly well
built and still surviving now because
they have not been modified and now we
come to this interesting from what do we
do as modernist if we have to restore a
historic building because if you do that
if you do this that this reaction that's
reactionary that is conservative
restoration yet that is what the Como
demands of architects to do which is
contradiction of the heart of Venice
cutter venice demands if you restore
historic monument you have to show in
material in proportion in color in
character in technology that you build
of our time and that you mark this
building in such a way that cannot be
misunderstood for previous period it's a
formula for rape and that's what many
architects not do unfortunately but it's
so funny that they give special
allowance for for this kind of Billings
is a painting by Carlo in his friend
painter with us often paintings of
classical classical architects now and
this is the project for the nouveau
pisaq PASOK is mccarty or refugees
outside Bordeaux which was cozies first
major urban project which was built and
I think also to this day is most
successful one it is also on the other
hand was very unintuitive in the urban
the sense it was just a loop road with
the cul-de-sac repetitive building types
the de Grazia the zigzag diesel aid and
what he condemned himself in Varanasi
dead clearly vision deploy describes
very precisely how he condemns the
illusion of symmetry when it is not
perceptible from a normal observation
now you have this axis
symmetry which is absolutely meaningless
when you walk in the street - absolutely
you see nothing of the symmetry you only
see it's for Bertha so it's a mechanical
symmetry which is in a way meaningless
and wasted wasted on a vernacular but
the house types are extraordinarily
attractive there have been many of these
house had been terribly violated and
Philippe would not write a book about
this know that and copy is supposed to
have said la vie gang and because they
have been so degraded but they are in
fact so beautiful that they are now
being restored by people who live there
and is a fan club of isaku who restore
beautifully those buildings and it's
very well worth looking at this what
what I think is little weak is exactly
this is just very conventional loop with
the cul-de-sac and then the buildings
are just lined up the traditional
urbanism would look at the whole picture
how does does this fit into a much
larger of an organism a plan Edwards
no continuations networking with
neighboring communities have squares for
use which are non-residential and have
much more interesting street scape but
in this case using Cobras is building
types because they are so interesting
well you see the building Lots obviously
spending lots and fees of the revised
building notes so I think I mean we
won't redo this one but one could
actually do a new quarter like that very
successfully this is the co busy
situation with the building types 708
building types existing and then I add
the market the circular merida caffeine
and a church of some sort and they are
situated then on squares which formed
the major on the major axis and it
becomes a place it's no longer suburb
it's no longer residential quarter
becomes real urban place a town the
church here would be this still in the
copy this time lit by huge skyline with
indirect light and that war would be
painted by this great painter I forget
his name is the most famous painter
there in Turkey 10 and this is
translation into a traditional aki 10
style here you see the Godsey l
translate into conventional they say
when you go to Whole Foods it says
organic or conventional this would be so
the same thing but you have the stack is
under under the overhang of the roof
otherwise it's rotting away and also a
roof garden is completely useless when
you don't have a room up there it's just
for no breathing but it's not for living
and I had the room up there so it really
becomes much more interesting and the
club and so on and that's the
translation into conventional style
color isn't it right here famous Villa
Stein Demasi with my preferred car it's
actually standing outside I think it's
the best piece of design of 20th century
that was sketch from
the 2003 excitement which we did with
Mark gage and he is this extraordinary
and it was the main subject of Colleen
Rose essay on transparency number two
and here you have when you look at
Kaposi's plan which is very impressive
the building but they're strange things
like you have the little double space
and then the stair which goes up without
and the main room which has no relation
to the main room which is this
extraordinary double height terrace but
you can't actually see into it so this
corrected here and you open that to the
main room and you have instead of having
the flat ceiling you have it actually
looks very much like some of
Mendelssohn's but this could be done
actually in stone stone lintels and
piers dimensionally it corresponds
exactly to the building and the
difference between front and back you
have this swelling out here and that
accounts for the days module which is
rigorously applied that's as is from
Adam Stein that's
probably much cheaper to maintain them
notice the importance of opening this up
to the main bedroom or the the living
room so weird to have the main room
there and you can't get out this becomes
much grander
that is the villas in invites enough
designed a lot by Alfred hot I think
from what we hear in this translated
again into traditional the building
construction again also here you have
the the roof come this yes is obsession
with having a single orientation in a
main room whereas the interest of a cone
of a corner is to have windows on in two
directions I mean that's a real luxury
or you have this this poor bedroom which
only looks out and has absolutely no
opening to the to the terrace which i
think is really a mistake
and you wouldn't let the student to that
so he is corrected and there are
variations regional variations of it now
the most is the most perfect creation
which I I might disagree with our Dean
who doesn't like philosopher I think I
enjoy it I find this absolutely it's
such a beautiful building that you want
to put a roof over it to protect it
against it is so fragile is so delicate
it's absolutely marvelous
but it's not made for this climate so it
is now placed here this from book of
quad class it's placed here and it's
like lost whereas he is allege a
landscape ledge he could have moved it
onto this ledge you would have
approached it by this Cornish Road and
then driven under opening the view talks
ascend and proceed until a quick sketch
as you would arrive and then put your
card in there and this tree which is
close to the kitchen so
what is it what is the problematic of
busy this is what they find traditional
architects climate soil attitude and he
had because of machinery and and fossil
fuel you can ignore climate but I think
not for long
he is Villa a reservist which was
designed for Chile these beautiful
drawings which are virtually 100%
vernacular there was a Japanese
architect who worked for him at the time
Bob I forgot the Mike Mike Haven Mike
heaven my okawa my account worked for Co
busy probably on this building he went
to Japan back to Japan worked for
Antonov mo and Don from mo but built
this and Co busy is virtually inside he
published in the second volume of our
complete saying pala petting the surgeon
a no no worry to know to be embarrassed
straight copy so here translate into
traditional fabric because there was
this strange butterfly roof which he
used again and again and and rigid
offices is very bad for a rain now the
famous Armada Sally
my preferred car a slight venerian style
here
this was co busy master plan for the
area this Armada salad and he planned
these very large blocks and here what
happened now disgusting bill absolutely
shocking in disgust and it's an
Institute for ancient languages can you
believe this poor people in this
horrendous buildings the Armada Salinas
terrible state is not being restored but
the quit Havener used this to make to
integrate into more delicate fabric and
another interesting thing is between
nineteen thirty seven thirty seven and
1945 the Germans and snarfer two worked
on the Albert Speer did several books
which were became major bestsellers for
architects after the war and in which
there is a very elaborate theory of
proportion actually elaborated by for
now effort by mr. Debose who was my
professor brief during my brief stay at
Stuttgart University and he didn't want
to talk about it but you find virtually
all copies diagrams for the modular you
find in these books from 1938 onward
done under the auspices of and Albert
repair now he is the proof of the
pudding now these are the the Nazi
buildings on Guernsey and on the French
coast and it is these buildings which
without any doubt influenced the Cobra
zis post-war style I mean they're direct
direct references to this building which
is the garbage collection pavilion next
to the anything Marseille I mean it
looks like exactly like that but I
recommend any visit this is an
extraordinary feeling to be up there I
was always intrigued by the
Capital insomnia and I'm still looking
for clients to build a capital city
that's didn't come forward easy but I
went there and I just completely changed
my mind about it because when I thought
that day I had a student and a free
student - what we got there said he was
not teaching in Chile and I gave him
this plan to urbanize because I said
this is my deal town the plan contains
the genes for an ideal town and just use
these as building blocks which he did
and which we published and was very nice
access but I think it was not the right
idea because in fact when you go there
the quality of the spaces between
despite the terrible state of the of the
buildings is very powerful and and
unique and I think it's it's something
which should be preserved now he for the
center was in 15 I was in 17 I think
it's the center of Chandigarh he
designed this module very large module
in order to for people to build in shops
and houses and and it looks absurd I
mean about that as they say in France
and that is really where the problem
lies at Cosi was a vernacular architect
he was not the classical Arabic he
developed modern architecture into
monumental vernacular because there is
no artistic elaboration the artistic
collaboration goes into painting into
enameled doors into sculptures but the
architecture itself is almost undiluted
vernacular concrete vernacular and of
course when that is taken over as in
this case as he had actually foreseen in
his a big project for for Algiers had
strangely foreseen what happened here in
a this kind of incredible vulgarity
which suddenly takes
takes over now another a part of this
project could be and I think Stanislaus
is going to work at this to assemble all
the architects who worked in that style
who recognized cozy as in stylistic
master and tried to work in that stand I
think there are some very good examples
like NOLA or Syrian in France or I think
he's actually the best is a student of
Syria and he worked briefly for Richard
Meyer and of course Michael Graves is as
Norman house and there were I think with
these people and with that style and
with a low fabric one could actually
build a very attractive town I think
would be formed a book to find all these
people and get them together because it
is really beginning of a language is not
very elaborate but I think it should be
developed and this coming back to
Chandigarh this really the poetry of
Chandigarh is this enormous spaces which
are really a recollection or a quotation
of the poetics of airfields this is
incredible beautiful atmosphere when
your nephew with his huge hangars and
beautiful and aeroplanes
and I think it is that which he was
after but what is missing is the fabric
because the Capitol is outside the city
nobody knows when you are cinder in
seventeen where's the Capitol nobody
knows where it is you show them the
photograph of the of the Assembly
Building they don't know where it is
xtronic the building the Capitol
building in China has no presents no
civic presence but this would be the
solution let's say these are traditional
neighborhoods quarters karti and you can
a very large space in between and then
have these monumental buildings attached
to now this could be the Justice this
could be governor palaces Parliament
linked to fabric so we have between this
vast park spaces of paved spaces which
could be actually very interesting but
on their own they are bit lost out there
facing the facing the Millea as you like
to see now with the students this year
we have done in a brief and extremely
interesting exercise we just to take the
Secretariat which is like a musical
score I mean so full of themes and
variations and sub-themes and shifting
and recollections and reversals and
crab-walk and so on that we took this
apart and made Navin ear out of it in
this brief vision
this was to day exercise of this Avenue
D secretary yeah
taking using only the architecture of
Secretariat and collaging it in such a
way that become so actually Kubizek
could become Navin architects the new
urban architect a real new modern new of
an architect these are more revisionist
interpretations of actually I use here
this fantastic thesis of Alex :
but the dispute phul thesis on the
governor's palace which i think is one
of the most powerful buildings ever
designed and which should be built
somewhere but we have to build it
somewhere full skyking well it's the
problem is it's the villas avoir again
and some of the themes and variations
which I constantly have in my own
projects this is like a vision of a
different author Ashanti God and this is
an painting by Professor Koski in not
rodham done in the style of the daniel
brothers who were famous illustrators of
the early 9th century in india and so on
so themes and themes and they recur and
finally when you do this exercise you
actually find that most of his teams in
the 12 portraits of the Dark Age the
shuttles the monumental eyes chapters
there are themes which were or had been
exercised in in traditional marketing
this is the last product which is the
church in Germany which has been
finished by Jo Jo Bobby Cobb is a wet
been disengaged fascist is most
important three most important friends
were importantly the French fascist
movement work Toby she for three years
and then after the war immediately after
the war he is employed by using hardness
patty to build the unity who was
minister of reconstruction to built in
eighteen marseille he was an important
person in the in the resistance and he
became mayor of fermi knee and he
created this film anywhere which is
green Germany against the dank dark
stone Germany and covers even had the
job to design this campus made of the
popular church be seen and then Stadium
and they are the urbanism again is very
poor would I propose the church is very
very interesting very powerful and very
beautifully built and actually executed
and that proposes to complete the film a
need appear along this pool but which
will be a separation between Germany the
Pierre a vimini there and integrate this
church with vergence key finish this and
the existing buildings in to need
complete traditional fabric this nun in
the coffee style now
before and after an urban square
I improvised here my I'm bit rusty in
this style but and this is translated
into traditional style so we live in
democracy so there should be choice
as you see this is my old project 1976 I
won these competitions in in Paris or la
Villette which was the villa savoir and
practically I know this more sorry yes
this is the correction of the
ministerial deliver fear on what is
solid you all know it now why would I do
that
because cause I didn't do it he didn't
get the job but he claimed the building
and I think that building would have
been much better reduced to three floors
there's this very grand there the
Pilates have really very powerful poetic
and and practical purpose and I send
this to Stanley Larsen and he says why
do you do this because this looks now
like a suburban shopping mall and then I
send him this now where every single
building around would have the same
height then he said I got
grab it because Kobe is better in three
stories anybody is better when you have
low fabric very few people are able to
do really tall tall buildings and
particularly tall utilitarian buildings
and this would have been the right way
to do it to relate to the church have a
series of nice squares and so the
village he built for Alison boom near in
the province which has very almost
vernacular architecture built in enough
and I just made this more interesting
following the topographic situation and
this is the last one is worn off so mer
corrected not translated but corrected
because there's something really weird
and also the great moment in this church
is this now what he learned from the
villa arianna is light streaming in from
the tower and making this absolute if
you want to have a sacred space
experience that's it but the main altar
is embarrassing because you get the
sparkling lights don't don't work and
this was using that idea to have the
main altar there and just have this Hart
chapel here right we'll make this grant
because this is a spectacular theatrical
space to be under here I think that's it
folks thank you very much
Thank You leo challenging view of
architectural history of the 20th
century I'm sure there must be one or
two questions or a polemic bursting out
of the audience at this point
professor vid where are you looking
about ready to say something that was
French yes sir
wait a minute we'll get you a microphone
Leon I have a question for you any
proposal for their poll rules by Lyndon
oh yes oh yes he gave me designs for the
rudolph building and the addition I had
them in my office upstairs we will have
them in a show next spring doesn't
forget to say thank you
it's harder questions or observations
yes thank you
angry proposals and in your experience
is the role of know your name in English
yes they are going to yes the acceptor
dinner and then some but what if we like
it
other questions this is the subject of a
book Alan you're gonna wait a minute I
will tell it an anecdote that I think is
true but one's memory fades I think one
of the first times you visited Yale we
walked around together and you hadn't
been since Lukens British Art Center was
finished and as we were walking down the
other side of the street you pointed to
it and said is that Liu Khan's British
Art Center and I said yes it's a
wonderful building but its best inside
let's go and you said no it looks very
much like I expected so I think you're
you're next you're next
that's what I said what's next maybe you
need to work on some of those buildings
oh we did that one year studio that you
did redo this it's all been done
this the the to count buildings and the
trust I think I think demolition is the
easy way out
demolition is perhaps the easy way out
there are other questions or
observations if not we thank our speaker
and we'll join him in the second floor
on the on the second floor in the
gallery for a reception